this North Carolina or North Korea this
is North Korea back to North Korea now
and then so now if uh I mean not North
Korea South Korea
[Music]
so does anybody happen to remember back
in 2017 there was this chick right who
like got stranded on the side of a
highway or something like that in Canada
and then this homeless dude comes and
helps her out in some way so then she
throws a GoFundMe it was a big scam
we're not doing that record what that's
not no it's not I didn't say it's an
operator wait Joe holy [__]
so um
he put together this GoFundMe to try and
raise ten thousand dollars right for
this Good Samaritan homeless dude it
ended up getting I believe four hundred
thousand dollars in online donations
and it ended up not so much becoming a
scam like it was a fake home student and
he was in auditor and she just kept it
that kind of scam yes her and her
boyfriend kept it or some [__] yeah
exactly so I don't know why people don't
do that more often he had only the the
homeless man ended up only receiving I
believe about
seventy thousand dollars or something
like that this is good yeah
[Laughter]
yeah for taxes and stuff admin fees
GoFundMe how to take a cut
and then they had to buy a house to
house a unhoused right so the three of
them didn't get together and manufacture
that whole story
I thought it was all fake we should do
that I think it actually started from an
actually Good Samaritan type of real
situation but I think it was one of
those things where it's like oh let's
raise ten thousand dollars and then when
like [__] 400 000 it wasn't about
changing that guys life anymore it was
like our lives can change and suddenly
whoa an agreed Factory kicked in because
once they saw four zero zero and zero
zero zero instead of just four zero zero
they went
you know what he kind of deserves being
homeless doesn't he yeah people like
seventy thousand will do yeah we worked
hard
we should get this money
that's what happened because they
promoted it right yep we did they told
the stories that's like an artist and
manager you know it's like we [__]
were the business behind it you just
[__] did your art homeless man it's
like the artist and then the record
label the record label they're the
record label and then the homeless guy
was just homeless in he goes you got you
didn't do [__] you just you're yourself
you just did your talent he was a
homeless veteran
even better
with anything he just says even better
ask him he's a homeless hula hooper okay
whatever it is well that changes
everything
he owes me 70 000 better in part always
makes people go oh man you fought for
the country that made me for that and
you still begging for money nah if that
was true people would take care of them
more I feel the opposite when I go to
[__] like so Nevada is crazy like
veteran friendly right like I'll go to
the DMV oh did you know if you go to
this Hall uh in City Hall you don't have
to pay car registration and I go over
here oh did you know if you do this you
have that because you're a veteran yeah
and the more things I went to City Hall
got the paperwork does not pay
registration anymore the more [__] that
I find out the more I feel less sorry
for veterans I'm like there's no way you
should make it on the streets because
this [__] the World's Gonna help your
ass dude what the [__] dude that's a
great take because you don't hear it
that often but it's probably true
because you do get benefits like a lot
of veterans get discounts all the time
dude you can go [__] get the VA and
get your [__] eyes checked and [__]
and [__] see if your feet smells and
they'll fix you AAA discounts see if
your feet smells and they fix you they
got all kinds of medical [__] all
kinds of [__] yeah yeah yeah this guy
stinks here let's pick something
dude the veteran Community they get
hooked up like crazy the ones I do feel
bad for are the ones that they have like
the Charities for were like [__] legs
blown off and they're they're like a
hundredth in line at the hospital and
they still can't get seen stuff like
that but then the The Bare Bones regular
veteran [__] that anyone could just walk
into an office is plentiful because just
walk into the office there there has to
be veterans that like didn't really do
much in the war right in their army or
whatever whoa wow slow zoom on Nick they
can still go and get their feet right if
they're a mailman in World War II
they were sending messages right they
could still that guy that [__] didn't
do anything you see time like me you see
I didn't do anything either he could
still get his registration [__] taken
care of yeah that's pretty why was
guarding supplies yeah yeah I said no
one via Excel sheet no one's touching
these canteens yeah unless I put my dick
in them
[Laughter]
notation okay
went to Korea and guarded a graveyard
that's that's some hard question from
which direction I guarded a graveyard in
North Carolina from the ghost
he went to Korea whoever's supposed to
go and spoke fake Korean I was a
translator and I manned like a general's
[__] comms desk and you know the the
Korean generals are actually very nice
really yeah so over here we have a uh
lower rank eats first
you know what I mean like when you go to
the child hall or whatever yeah the
lower ranks go first the higher rigs
stay in the back in Korea that's
different so like you know like like the
whole hyung concept yeah so the the
generals they go and eat first but even
before the generals the foreigners eat
first oh
so that's even though I'm [__] low
ranking they're like oh you get to go
first and a friend of me so I get to
stand with the general and [__] and then
their child Hall is [__] [__]
Mandu [__] noodles and all kinds of
he even said noodles like fluffy
it was way different dude and I got to
eat in [__] Korean atmosphere Wow
versus what does that mean like it's
Korean restaurant Korean restaurant
like they serve you and do this like
American military bases it feels like a
military base you know I mean it's like
wow is this wall ready to disassemble
tomorrow it's like that over there it
felt yeah that [__] like a blue heron
[__] thing there's like neon signs
and Soju Zoe describe you guys were just
at a Korean restaurant at a buffet
welcome to the Korean military
I'll show you pictures in the middle of
the base the middle of the base look
like the Huntington Library there's a
[__] little Pagoda and [__] like
[__] Lotus pads on a pond ready for
people to go
damn [__] that is nice our bases do not
look like no pagodas at our bases huh
nope and you get benefits for that I
don't know about the benefits but I
liked that that was oh do I get benefits
for that yeah anybody does yeah
people can smell his feet and fix him
yeah yeah yeah you're right you're right
what's like the most boring job you had
to do
my most boring job probably his actual
job
guarding a graveyard is pretty crazy
dude that was pretty boring because my
shift was also from like two was it the
graveyard shift it was actually nice get
the hell out of here it was a two to six
and you're not really allowed to sleep
yeah and then they always do like radio
like little radio check over and they
want to make sure like school I'm always
I was like
there's somebody here I just lay up
against the tombstone I just put it
right here
he got caught sleeping oh I don't
I don't no bueno man I don't know why
were you guys guarding the graveyard
were they talking to you in Korean on
the radio this is a North Carolina now
what the [__] not North Korea
is it North Korea when they found out
you're useless in the Korean military
what did they do
there's being a man on the phone
so it's literally just someone calling
to see if the phone works are the lines
when you are a lower rank you don't do
you do Jack you get like dumb jobs like
that you get to [__] walk in mud into
this random tent and then you just sit
there and then you look over into the
other room and then his [__] generals
like
oh
they're planning all these things and
they're just like
hey Eagle One do you read me yeah okay
cool see you later bye-bye
[Laughter]
and you can see it visually yeah it
looks fun hey this phone still works by
the way anybody you guys are wondering
does anyone need a phone
if you go over and go into General stand
be like hey general just to let you know
the phone's still working if you need to
use it every hour right do a check let
me know if you need any help and
someone's checking on YouTube to make
sure that you're doing that
um well it's like uh what is it called
check some checks and balances Chinese
finger trap comes over and he said he
comes over and then we take a note
you're expressing your gesture today are
so [__] good like Kawaii
you know the international son no this
new Senpai what happens when you call
and you get no reception you go can you
hear me oh did I immediately have to
report it because we're checking to make
sure comms stay open so if a big move is
about to go down like so we're real
we're uh what's the training exercise is
called like
it's called a UFL or some [__] and we're
trying to
um
play out scenarios if North Korea
attacked that's what we're trying to do
so that's the way the comms have to stay
open this is North Carolina or North
Korea this is North Korea back to North
Korea now and then so now if uh I mean
not North Korea South Korea whoa
um Eagle one we got a problem over here
that was classified highly by the way
[__] yeah I just know it's a different
dialect I don't speak
yeah so if I if I send communication
over and there's nothing on the other
side then I immediately have to report
it and they have to establish another
line of communication that person's
probably big trouble because you have to
it's pretty much like if General the
general can't speak whenever the [__]
they want with something big happens
then we're in big big trouble yeah so
we're just in charge of like
okay and then another hour
damn yeah and then from that you get
medical you get sick you get you get
paid you get your school paid for all
kinds of [__] I should have went to the
military man don't you get zero down
loans at low interest rates VA loans is
also awesome you don't you get zero
percent down
that's why I hear all these things I'm
like you want to sleep on the sidewalk
that's your bad dude
join the military brother oops all
sidewalk
[Music]